ان نرصد معك ايضا هشام باقي الجوانب
المرتبطه بالمشهد
انسانيا المساعدات ما يصل منها ما يحتاجه
السكان والاهالي هناك ما طبيعه ما يشهده
المشهد الانساني
الان المشهد الانساني مريم صعب للغايه لا
سما ونحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 70 يوم من حرب
اسرائيليه والمساعدات التي تدخل هي
مساعدات بسيطه وشحيح وان هذه مساعدات اصلا
هي مساعدات مجانيه وبالتالي لا تستطيع
الناس الوصول اليها في كل المناطق ما يدخل
هو مساعدات تذهب الى وكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الاونر وتذهب الى جمعيات خيريه
وبالتالي توزعها على النازحين ومنهم من لا
يصل اليه اي من هذه المساعدات بالتالي
الناس تحتاج الى ان يكون هناك مواد
تموينيه و ودقيق وبعض المواد الاساسيه تصل
الى مراكز التسوق وبالتالي يستطيعون
شرائها باموالهم الان ما يدخل الى قطاع
غزه نحو 60 الى 100 شاحنه يوميا وهذه
المساعدات تدخل من دقيق ومواد تموينيه
الدقيق يذهب الى وكاله غوث وتشغيل الانرو
وتقوم بتوزيعه الى الناس عبر اليه يعني
كانت بداتها منذ بدايه هذه الحرب والمواد
التموينيه تستلمها ايضا الاونر ولكن
توزعها على الناس والنازحين في مدارسها
وبالتالي لا تصل الى السكان بينما الان كل
شيء مفقود الغذاء مفقود المواد الاساسيه
مفقوده الدقيق مفقود من الاسواق وايضا
الدواء مفقود حتى المياه مفقوده لا يوجد
مياه شرب في قطاع غزه لا سما في المناطق
الوسطى والجنوبيه فالحال في مناطق شمال
قطاع غزه ومدينه غزه اصعب بكثير وبمراحل
من هذه المناطق في وسط وجنوب القطاع لا
سما وان مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع الحصار
المفروض على هذه المناطق صعب للغايه الجيش
الاسرائيلي متواجد في قلب هذه المناطق
وبالتالي من الصعب بمكان التحرك والحصول
على المواد التموينيه والحصول على الماء
او حتى البحث عنه فبالتالي المناطق في وسط
قطاع غزه ربما تتواجد المياه في
المستشفيات ولا سما وانه يتواجد الكهرباء
رغم ان المستشفيات تعاني من نقص في الوقود
لكن رغم كل ذلك هي تحاول تلبيه بعض
احتياجات السكان وابرزها المياه لا سما
وان هناك عشرات بل الاف من النازحين ما
زالوا يتواجدون في المستشفيات ايضا
الادويه هناك نقص حاد في الادويه الادويه
غير موجوده موجوده في الصيدليات وبالتالي
الناس لا يستطيعون شرائها الادويه المزمنه
الادويه ادويه الانسولين الكثير من
الادويه التي يحتاجها ايضا الاطفال غير
موجوده في الصيدليات ولا حتى متوفره في
المستشفيات ومن يصل الى المستشفى مريض
يعني حتى يفقد حياته بسبب عدم وجود ادويه
ومستلزمات طبيه والعديد من المفقودات في
هذه المستشفيات التي تعاني من جراء هذه
الحرب الاسرائيليه المتواصله وبالتالي
هناك تحذيرات شديده من مؤسسات حقوقيه
ومؤسسات دوليه من ان هناك خطوره على سكان
قطاع غزه من الجوع ومن العطش جراء استمرار
هذا العدوان الاسرائيلي وجراء استمرار
الحصار الاسرائيلي المطبق على القطاع منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب اسرائيل قطعت الكهرباء
اطبقت الحصار اغلقت المعابر وبالتالي ما
يصل حتى الان هو نقطه في بحر احتياجات
سكان قطاع غزه الذين يحتاجون الى كل شيء
رغم ان الحرب مستمره ومتواصله فان
الاحتياجات كبيره وبالتالي الوضع يزداد
صعوبه في ظل هذه الاوضاع وفي ظل استمرار
هذه الحرب شكرا لك هشام زقوط كنت معنا من
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح